in all of science there are very few
statements that are absolutely true
and one of those is that you can't go
faster than the speed of light
that one is pretty safe
except
except it's not or more accurately like
any absolute statement you need to be
careful because such an assertion always
has some assumptions that are often left
unspoken
in this lecture we'll talk about the
various ways in which talking about the
speed of light can be confusing
but first let's talk about the speed of
light and what it is and what people
mean when they talk about note going
faster than light
we'll begin with what light is which is
a pretty basic thing i mean you all know
what light is it's a thing that lets us
see
light is the thing that comes out at the
end of a flashlight or brightens the sky
on a summer day
we will speak in a later lecture about
the nature of light whether it was a
wave or a particle
and what we're talking about here it's
rarely important to make the distinction
because the velocity of light doesn't
depend on its nature
in this lecture it's probably simplest
to think of light as a wave most of the
time so that's what we'll do
if it becomes important to make the
distinction i'll make that clear
so light is an electromagnetic field
traveling through space
it doesn't have to be visible light for
there are wavelengths that the eye can't
see there are radio waves and microwaves
infrared and ultraviolet x-rays and
gamma rays
all of these types of radiation travel
at the same speed as visible light and
just to be clear
within the range of visible light the
whole roy g biv spectrum of red orange
yellow green blue indigo and violet the
speed of light is identical for all of
those colors
now what do i mean when i say the speed
of light
i mean the speed of light in a vacuum
indeed most of the times where i talk
about variations in the speed of light
it will be in material
that's not 100 true but it mostly is
first what is the speed of light well
light moves incredibly quickly
so fast that it's hard to visualize
the speed of light is
186 000 miles per second
or if you're a metric kind of person
that is 299 million 792
458 meters per second
in order to get at least kind of a feel
for how fast that is light is so fast
that it could circle the earth seven and
a half times in a single second
by the way that number i gave you for
the speed of light in the vacuum in
meters is exact there are no additional
decimals
this is because since 1983 the
definition of a meter was redefined to
be the distance that light travels in
one over 299 million 792 458
of a second
so for those of you who like trivia you
only have to remember nine digits not
too bad
and you'll be the life of the party well
depending i suppose on the kind of
parties you attend
when you think about it how you measure
something that quick is quite a feat
you'd think that it would take the most
modern technology but the first
successful measurement of the speed of
light was accomplished in 1676.
danish astronomer olaf romer calculated
the orbits of the moons of jupiter down
to knowing exactly when the moons would
pass in front or behind the larger
planet
he also knew that depending on whether
jupiter was closer or more distant to
the earth in its orbit his calculations
would disagree with his predictions by
about a thousand seconds about 15
minutes
he surmised that the difference was due
to the amount of time it took for light
to travel from jupiter to the earth
knowing the distances and the time
differences he could work out the
velocities and determined that the speed
was 214 million meters per second or
about two-thirds the modern value
that was a pretty respectable effort
given that we're talking about almost
350 years ago
there were some other attempts using
astronomical approaches but the first
measurement of the speed of light
located entirely on the earth was french
physicist armand fazeau
he used a spinning gear a bright light
and a mirror located about five miles
away
he shined the light at a distant mirror
and saw when the light reflected back to
him by looking through the gears as they
spun
his measurement was 315 million meters
per second accurate to about five
percent
french physicist leon foucault did a
modified version of the experiment using
rotating mirrors that was accurate to
better than a percent
when what are called maxwell's equations
were written down in the late 1860 by
james clark maxwell it was possible to
calculate the speed of light using his
results to combine measurements taken of
the electrical and magnetic properties
of space
at that point the determination of the
speed of light was sufficiently accurate
that it became increasingly necessary to
account for the fact that light travels
at different speeds and materials than
it does in a vacuum
[Music]
so let's start with the bottom line in
most transparent materials like glass
water plastic etc
light travels at a lower speed than it
does in a vacuum
and the differences is pretty large
in glass and plastic light travels at
about two-thirds the speed it does in a
vacuum
in water it's a bit faster about 75
percent the speed of light in the vacuum
in diamond the effect is even greater in
diamond light travels at 40 percent
under half of its normal speed
in the visible spectrum diamond is
pretty much the record holder although
there are a few obscure materials that
beat it by just a bit but diamonds are
both familiar and pretty so let's give
them the credit
in other wavelengths other materials can
slow electromagnetic waves even more but
let's just stick with visible light
because it's familiar
when light hits a transparent medium it
literally slows down and then speeds up
again when it leaves
now i say literally and i mean it but
it's more complicated than you'd think
which is of course one of the topics
we'll cover
and even though you might have learned
that light still slows down in glass if
you ever took an introductory college
physics class you almost certainly
didn't through think through the idea of
something slowing down and then speeding
back up again i mean you know how to do
that in the car hit the brake and then
the accelerator but how do you
accelerate light
i better have you thinking now
the term that you might have learned for
this phenomena is simply the index of
refraction
the index of a fraction of materials
make the path of light bend when it
passes through the material
you can see this most easily by just
putting a pencil in a glass of water
it's pretty easy to see that this
bending is caused by the slowing of
light as it hits the material
there are tons of related explanations
but this is probably the easiest to see
let's think of light as a wave and what
you're seeing here are the peaks of the
wave as they travel through space as
they hit the surface of water or glass
or whatever they slow down
we'll get to the slowing mechanism in a
minute just accept that this is what's
going on just for a moment
light has four parameters that matter
the frequency of oscillation the
wavelength which is the color by the way
the velocity and the amplitude or
brightness
classically the brightness is the
strength of the electric field
the frequency is the number of
oscillations per second since the light
exists both outside and inside the
medium and further at the surface the
oscillation rate must be the same
that means that the frequency of the
light must be the same inside and
outside the medium
if the velocity slows down that means
that the waves move a smaller amount for
every period of time
since there has to be the same number of
oscillations per second that means that
the wavelength of light gets shorter
inside the glass or water or whatever
thus seeing the bending is evidence for
the slowing down in water
however that doesn't tell you what the
mechanism that actually slows down the
water
there are several explanations that you
can find in books
some of those invoke classical physics
and some of them attempt to use quantum
principles
it turns out that the classical mindset
is more accurate although perhaps
obviously all answers must eventually
originate somewhere in the quantum world
let's talk a bit about the classical
answer because it's easiest to
understand and it reflects pretty well
the right quantum answer
if you're a physics buff and you want to
understand this in detail i recommend
that you read the explanation given by
richard feynman in his lectures from
back in the 1960s
in essence
what is going on requires that you
remember what light actually is
light is an electric field that is
changing both in position and in time
visualize the peak of a water wave
passing over an otherwise still pond and
you got the big idea
the position of the peak changes over
time
now inside the material you have a bunch
of atoms just chalk a block full of
electrons
electrons are lightweight particles with
electric charge
particles with electric charge feel
electric fields and start moving
but moving electric charges make moving
electric fields and so inside the
material you have a very complicated
situation
you have the electric field of the
original beam of light but you also have
jiggling electric fields of the
electrons
these electric fields add together and
what moves through the material is the
mix of fields and that mix moves slower
than light
suppose you have two sets of electric
fields that move at somewhat different
speeds the combination of the two fields
can move at a velocity different from
either of the two fields
so that's the basic reason why light
moves more slowly in material than in a
vacuum it's because the light in the
material is a mix of electric fields
including electric fields originating in
the material itself
and that's the basic idea
i'd like to dispel a misconception that
you often see on the internet about
what's going on in the quantum level you
find many people that talk about how
light is made of photons and that
photons can be absorbed by charged
particles like electrons
these people claim that if you shoot a
single photon at a piece of material
that it will move more slowly while in
the material that's true
but the mechanism they invoke is all
wrong basically what they claim is that
the photon jumps from atom to atom
electron to electron getting absorbed
waiting for a tiny fraction of time then
getting emitted by that atom so it can
travel to the next atom
they describe describe it kind of like a
person with a ton of friends traveling
across the country
the friendly traveler finds an old
friend spends the night at their house
then travels to the next friend and
stays at their house day after day the
traveler moves and then spends the night
the result is that the traveler has an
effective speed that is slower than they
would have if they drove constantly
there's only one problem this definitely
doesn't happen
in our next couple of lectures we'll
talk about quantum mechanics and how
materials absorb and emit light
every atom of each element has a
characteristic and specific set of
energy levels that they can absorb and
emit
you've probably seen what happens when
you take light from a glowing gas and
send it through a prism
that light has specific colors specific
wavelengths which means specific energy
that's true in a gas than in the solid
but versions of it happen in both
if you send light into a piece of
transparent glass
all wavelengths get through equally or
at least pretty much so this idea of
light being absorbed waiting for a bit
and getting re-emitted is just wrong
don't believe it
the reality is more like the classical
version when you mix atoms into
individual molecules or even more
complex into extended solids and liquids
the idea of electrons and atoms and
fixed energies is just not true anymore
atoms share electrons the energy levels
change radically
instead of each atom having fixed
energies molecules and more complicated
structures have a continuum of energy
levels the net effect is that as a
photon travels through transparent
matter it doesn't hit individual atoms
with individual electrons instead the
electric field of the photon
moves the location and changes the
energy of many electrons and you're
basically back to the classical
description
[Music]
so it's totally true that light
traveling through transparent materials
travel slower than it does through a
vacuum
this means that even though we say that
nothing can travel faster than light we
really mean only in a vacuum and matter
it's actually pretty easy for particles
to travel faster than light can in the
same material
imagine for a moment that you have a
photon beam and a high energy muon beam
pointed in the same direction
a muon is like an electron's chubbier
cousin and i picked it because it avoids
complications that would bother a purist
if you're more comfortable imagining an
electron that works too as long as we
ignore a few effects that aren't central
to what i'm talking about
to avoid the issues of the last topic we
discussed let's assume that these beams
are initially in a vacuum
the photon beam of course travels at the
speed of light and for the purposes of
my example let's say that the muon beam
is traveling at 99.99
the speed of light
so to all intents and purposes you'd say
that they were traveling at about the
same speed
what happens if you shoot both of them
into a giant block of glass
well we established in the last section
that when light hit the glass it would
slow down
in ordinary glass the speed of light
inside the material is about two-thirds
the speed of light in a vacuum
so what happens to the muon
it turns out that it doesn't slow down
when it passes into the glass to all
intents and purposes it just barrels
along still going at
99.99 the speed of light
so that means in a material like water
glass or even air it's possible for an
object to move faster than light does in
that material
okay so that's the first lesson while
it's impossible to go faster than light
in a vacuum it's actually pretty easy
for objects to go faster than light
through something like glass
and you want to know how we know about
this
when we when this happens it makes glass
glow a lovely blue color
this light was discovered back in the
1930s by a young russian physics student
by the name of pavel cherenkov
he was working with uranium salts which
were dissolved in sulfuric acid
when he did this he saw that the
solution glowed at the time uranium
research was still pretty new especially
back in the soviet union
it was thought that the glow was caused
directly by radioactivity but as he
tried to isolate the effect he found
that he could see the glow in a test
tube containing nothing more than pure
sulfuric acid if the test tube was near
a highly radioactive substance
this is an analogy and shouldn't be
taken seriously but you could kind of
imagine it like a black light and a
black light poster with the radiation
being the black light and the sulfuric
acid being the poster
in the same way that black light will
make the poster glow radiation made the
sulfuric acid glow
trankov eventually was able to show that
even water would glow in the presence of
a lot of radiation
he shared his work with sergey vavlov
who was his thesis advisor
vavalov mentioned the effect to igor tam
and ilya frank who figured out what was
going on
whatever you might think of the soviet
union they had some awfully sharp minds
cherenkov tam and frank shared the 1958
nobel prize in physics
before i tell you how cherenkov
radiation works let's just talk about
what it looks like shall we
imagine water surrounding a nuclear
reactor
the blue light you'd see is the
cherenkov radiation being made in the
water it's really quite beautiful in a
terrifying kind of way
without the water to shield the
radiation taking that photo might have
made the photographer quite ill
but the water both shielded the
dangerous radiation and made the
shrink-off radiation
there's nothing dangerous or all that
special about shrink off radiation it's
just blue light
but how is it made
basically it's analogous to a sonic boom
when a jet flies faster than the speed
of sound
a jet flies at a high velocity but one
that is lower than the speed of sound as
it moves through the air it compresses
the air in front of it
that compressed energy moves away at the
speed of sound however as the jet moves
faster and faster it gets to the point
where it's moving along with the
compressed air right in front of it
that means that more and more sound is
moving along with it and that sound is
moving at the single speed
and if that compressed air passes over
you it's incredibly loud because all of
the sound arrives at once
now if the plane moves faster than sound
the sound waves don't stack up like they
did when the plane was moving at the
speed of sound but instead what happens
is that each location the plane makes
sound from pushing the air out of the
way and that sound leaves the location
at which it was made traveling in all
directions at the speed of sound
it makes a series of circles appearing
at each point the plane passes
the circles add up and make a cone of
sound that surrounds the path of the
plane
shrink of light is about the same thing
except that it occurs when a charged
particle passes through a transparent
material at speeds faster than light
passes through the material
the electric charge of the particles
jiggle the molecules of the material and
they give off light as they move
the charge particle moves on and jiggles
more molecules
and you see what happens the light
emitted in the material leaves where it
was created traveling outwards in a
circular pattern at the speed of light
and the net result is another cone
pattern this one being what we call
cherenkov light
cherenkov light is actually useful for
some physicists to study what happens in
some nuclear physics or particle physics
experiments
since churrenkov light is only emitted
by electrically charged particles moving
through a transparent medium faster than
light does
scientists can exploit this to
distinguish quickly moving particles
from slower ones
the fast ones give off cherenkov light
while the slow ones don't
[Music]
so far we've spoken of cases where light
slows down and instances where particles
move faster than that slow light
there are actually two physical cases
where phenomena can move faster than
light even in a vacuum
one of these involves quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics is very tricky and i'm
going to devote two entire lectures to
misconceptions involving the topic
since those are the next two i'm not
going to describe here in detail about
traveling faster than light in quantum
situations
it's a real thing though
when you make a measurement in certain
quantum mechanical situations it
certainly appears that the news that a
measurement was made does actually
travel faster than light
you can't use the phenomena to transmit
information so it doesn't break
einstein's theory of special relativity
but it happens
you have to wait until the next couple
of lectures to hear more about it
but there's another situation where
objects can move faster than light well
kind of sort of i guess
i probably should explain
in our last lecture we spoke about the
big bang and how the universe has been
expanding for eons
this has an important bearing on another
way in which the phrase moving faster
than light is at least partially real
as a reminder it was in 1929 that
american astronomer edwin hubble
combined the distance measurements that
he made of galaxies with the velocity
measurements made by american astronomer
vesto sliffer and others and made a very
intriguing plot
on the horizontal axis is the distance
of galaxy in his study as measured from
earth and the vertical axis is their
velocity
hubble hypothesized that there was a
linear relationship between the two and
you can see his estimate on his graph
1929 was a long time ago when people
have done better in the intervening
years
there are more modern versions of
hubble's plot i'm showing an example
here and it also can be find in the
guidebook to give an idea how much
better the newer plot is hubble's
original data would fit in the tiny red
box down in the corner
his idea of a linear correlation between
distance and recessional velocity seems
to have been correct
as we learned in the last lecture
this correlation is taken to be a clear
evidence for an expanding universe and b
the big bang
but let's think about what it means
the expansion of the universe has
changed over time it was originally very
fast after the big bang 14 billion years
ago but the attraction of gravity slowed
it down for about 9 billion years about
5 billion years ago a form of repulsive
gravity called dark energy came to
dominate the cosmos and the expansion is
now speeding up
a quantitative discussion needs to take
into account all of this
however
we can make the key points even ignoring
these details
using modern data and taking hubble's
idea that the recessional velocity is
proportional to distance
we can figure out the slope of the graph
we find that in round numbers the
recessional velocity
is 70 kilometers per second per
megaparsec a megaparsec is equivalent to
3.26 million light years
so in english what this says is that a
galaxy that's a mega parsec away will be
moving away from the milky way at a
speed of 70 kilometers per second
at a distance of 2 megaparsics our
galaxy will be moving away at a speed of
140 kilometers per second three
megaparsecs 210 kilometers per second
the further and further away you go the
faster the objects are moving
taking hubble's linear relationship is
accurate which we know isn't perfectly
right but we're going to do it anyway
we can find out that there's a distance
where galaxies move away from the milky
way at the speed of light
taking a speed of 300 000 kilometers per
second for the speed of light and a
hubble relationship of 70 kilometers per
second per megaparsec we can divide the
two and we find the distance at which
objects are moving away at the speed of
light is 4285mhz
or 14 billion light years
now these numbers aren't right due to
changes in the expansion history of the
universe but let's use them
they mean that an object that is 14
billion light years away is moving away
from us at the speed of light
or does it
you certainly hear statements like that
actually when i hear from a non-expert
they often say something like the
universe is expanding at the speed of
light
which is obviously nonsense or at least
awfully incomplete
for instance what the heck do they mean
the universe includes the solar system
and clearly pluto isn't expanding away
from us at the speed of light
neither is the milky way nor the
andromeda galaxy which is a couple of
million light years away
actually andromeda is heading towards
the milky way and the two of them will
collide in a billion years or a few
anyway
supporting the people who say that the
universe is expanding at the speed of
light
it's true that we calculate that objects
14 billion light years away are
traveling away from us at that speed
but objects 28 billion light years away
are traveling away from us at twice the
speed of light so the whole expanding
faster than the speed of light assertion
is really pretty mushy
so what is right is the speed of light
the ultimate speed well yes in a manner
of speaking
remember typically the first statements
about not going faster than light are
made within the theory of special
relativity
in special relativity space doesn't
change shape it doesn't move it
certainly doesn't expand
space or more accurately space time is
flat
light moves in space time and there
light is the maximum speed
in general relativity space does bend
and warp and expand
to connect it to special relativity you
have to treat each spot in spaces
entirely flat
if you know calculus that means you have
to treat each point as a differential
volume element and if calculus isn't
your thing or if it's been a while
it means that in general relativity you
take the entire universe and slice it up
into a near infinite number of tiny
cubes
you keep making the cubes smaller and
smaller until in each one it's safe to
say that inside the cube that space is
flat and then in the cube the laws of
special relativity hold
so when we're talking about the speed of
light through space we're talking about
a flat space time
however if space is expanding that's a
different thing
we just talked about two objects that
are locally stationary in their little
cube but the cubes are moving apart at
the speed of light or even more
now if two objects are far enough apart
that the distance between them is
increasing faster than light then if one
of them shoots a beam of light at the
other
then the light will never get there in a
very real sense it's like an old steam
driven paddle boat that can move at five
miles per hour
if you try to have it move upstream but
the current downstream is 10 miles per
hour the paddle boat will be carried
downstream
this also means that at a distance
beyond 14 billion light years the two
galaxies can never talk to one another
even in principle
and remember what i said in the last
lecture about how the expansion of the
universe can make the numbers confusing
an object whose light was emitted 14
billion years ago and is now just
arriving at earth is currently 46
billion light years away so i hope you
focus more on the ideas than the exact
numbers here getting numbers precisely
correct requires a considerably greater
amount of care and nuance
getting back to the question of moving
faster than light are two galaxies
separated by 14 billion light years
moving away from each other at the speed
of light
well yes and no
it's true that the distance between them
is growing at the speed of light but
relative to their little local bit of
space
they're not even moving
the bottom line is that while light only
moves through space at the speed of
light the expansion of space can be
faster so it's possible to be sloppy and
say that objects can move apart faster
than light but it's more accurate to say
that objects cannot move through space
faster than light but space itself
can move faster than light
now this doesn't help us with warp drive
or hyperspeed or any of those things
from science fiction but personally i
think this super luminal expansion of
the distant universe is just the coolest
thing
it makes me wonder just how big the
universe really is and it makes me sad
that we'll never know the answer to that
simple question
you